قالت لي
اني احمل مبادره ان تطلب يعني بحكم محبه
الرئيس الك واعتزازه فيك واهتمامك وثقتي
فيك احنا قواتنا في وضع حرج جدا بالفلوجه
تقاتل يعني تنظيمات مسلحه وما ولا يمكن ان
نسمح لامريكا ان تهان فاحنا اما ان نبيد
الفلوجه عن بكره ابيها بسلاح نوعي او
تعاني امريكا ولا يمكن ان تهانئ بان نسمح
بهانت امريكا العرض هو ان يخرج الرئيس
يكتب لك رساله للشعب
يكتب ما يشاء بها بس
لبه الرساله لب الرساله انه يكتب يطلب من
المسلحين وقف القتال وقف القتال والتفاوض
مع القوات الامريكيه مقابل هذا الى يعني
حددوا عده طرق منها يطلق سراحه ومنها يطلق
صراحه فورا خارج العراق خارج الى خارج
العراق حددوا له ثلاث دول عربيه يختار اي
دوله من هاي الدول العربيه
واكدوا لي انه يعني جيبه متصل بالخزينه
العراقيه يعني ما يشيل هم الامور الماليه
او الامور المعيشيه ما يكتب مذكرات
يعتزل السياسه
ما يلتقي باحد يعني مجرد يعني حياه وحددون
ثلاث عواصم عربيه حددوها
[موسيقى]
يعني ماذا قال لك عندما عرضت عليه ذلك